[Music]
Ronnie ortiz-magro ex-girlfriend Jen
Harley was arrested on Sunday on one
count of domestic battery et can confirm
her bail was set at three thousand
dollars and she is already out of
custody the charge stems from an alleged
fight that you had on a drive home from
a barbecue the Jersey Shore star
reportedly demanded Harley pull over at
which point she allegedly took off
driving while he was caught in the
seatbelts but this isn't the first time
the pair's troubles have played out in
the public eye just a few weeks after
welcoming their first child ariana sky
in April the reality star and his ex
reportedly split after a fight allegedly
got physical
Harley even went live on Instagram
documenting one of their arguments in
May there was speculation that the
couple might be getting back together
when ortiz-magro posted a sweet moment
of Harley sleeping in bed on Mother's
Day to his Instagram story but the cast
of Jersey Shore family vacation recently
told et there's more drama to come for
the two on the second season of the
series
[Music]
[Music]